i'm audiologist dr emily taylor and i'll
be answering your twitter questions
today this is hearing support
[Music]
all right lexa marexa wants to know how
do ears work please send help this is a
model of the ear let's bring it here
right here you see the pinna this is the
large part of your ear
that is for funneling sound waves into
your ear canal so when the sound wave
enters your ear canal it's going to make
it down to your eardrum which is going
to vibrate your eardrum back and forth
behind the eardrum it is an air-filled
chamber called your middle ear right
here are the three smallest bones in
your body called your ossicles when the
eardrum moves back and forth it is
moving the ossicular chain back and
forth as well that chain actually
amplifies the vibrations and sends it
into the inner ear which you can see
here it's called your cochlea inside the
cochlea it is fluid filled which is
really important to know which
stimulates different hair cells that are
tonotopically organized which means they
all are responsible for different
frequencies and then from the hair cell
it's going to send electrical signals up
your auditory nerve and send it to the
brain where we process sound and
understand it acts 20 is asking ear
infection what am i a child so yes there
is a higher incident rate of ear
infections among children but we do see
them in adults as well the most common
you would see is an outer ear infection
which right here on my little model
there are a few different reasons but
it's typically from a buildup of
bacteria in your ear swimmer's ear is
what they are commonly calling it which
is just when you've got a lot of moist
water in your ear canal that just gets
left there and that's a breeding ground
for bacteria so it is important to keep
your ears dry like just taking a towel
to your ear and drying it off also
putting your ear down letting the water
run out naturally or putting your blow
dryer on a very low setting and just
blowing it near your ear wither and see
sweet
what the [ __ ] is ear candling and why
would you pay for it don't pay for it
it's a hoax this is a really dangerous
thing that's going around on the
internet what it is is you're lighting a
candle coming out of your ear which some
people believe creates a vortex which
can suction out your earwax at the end
of that procedure you look in the candle
and people see stuff that's actually
just parts of the candle that you're
seeing that is not the actual debris
coming out of your ear some interesting
videos to watch would be when they put
one in the ear and then right next to it
they put one in a cup and you see the
same things inside of the candling also
it does not get hot enough to actually
create suction and you're lighting a
fire by your head so that to me just
already sounds like a bad idea so don't
waste your money on it don't buy it and
don't let your friends do it to you next
question is from j.l rumer is apple's
conversation boost essentially making
the airpod a hearing aid if so i'm sold
on it apple does have this conversation
boost feature what it's doing is
basically giving you a directional
microphone so that you hear directly in
front of you and then trying to cut back
on the sound around you some of the
reviews say it sounds a little unnatural
because you're actually not sure how
loud the background noise is other
people find it really helpful it
definitely can make speech coming from
in front of you a lot clearer and louder
if you find it helpful go ahead and use
it there's no downside to it apple's
conversation boost is different from a
hearing aid a hearing aid itself we
would program it to your hearing loss
and just give you back the frequencies
you are missing where this does not take
into account your hearing loss nowadays
some hearing aids don't use the
directional microphones anymore hearing
aids do have two microphones that is how
we do better in background noise but
it's not just pointing a signal right in
front of you because you want to hear
all around you so that's a big
distinction between the two stimi sky
sent in the question how do hearing aids
work i mean if you have a drop in
specific frequencies do they amplify
specifically these frequencies or just
make everything louder that is such a
good question a lot of times you'll see
these really inexpensive hearing aids
advertised online those are just
amplifiers they are making everything
louder but unfortunately loudness does
not equal clarity so that is why a
hearing aid is so much more
sophisticated it's not just making
things louder or trying to make things
sound clear and natural so a hearing aid
has a few different parts to it this is
an example of a hearing aid some of the
main components are in this back piece
which sit behind your ear in this tiny
packaging there is a very sophisticated
chip some of the chips actually have
what's called a deep neural network that
has 20 million sound samples stored on
it so that when you hear a sound the
hearing aid can actually put it on a map
and figure out what it is like a bird
chirping or a tea kettle going off
there's also microphones on board which
sends the signal to an amplifier which
then it's produced in the speaker
directly into your ear canal some really
cool things about hearing aids today is
that they are bluetooth compatible so
you can stream audio from your cell
phones and different devices but a
really important thing to remember is a
hearing aid it's not canceling the
background noise it's just trying to
adjust the signal to noise ratio so that
what's important like the speech signal
is gonna come above the background noise
so you can actually hear it without
having to work hard question from
frankenmonster what is the purpose of
ear wax it does this world no good there
are a few purposes to it it's actually
quite important to have it first of all
we have glands in our ear canal they
produce the earwax earwax is
antimicrobial so it can prevent
infections in your ear it can also
hydrate the skin if you didn't have that
your ear might be itchy or dry another
reason we have earwax is to prevent
debris from getting all the way down to
your eardrum so earwax is really
important to have people are always
thinking it's like the enemy but we
produce it on purpose and your ear
actually self-cleans say that back to me
it self cleans people are obsessed with
putting things in their ears right now
you should not put anything in your ears
to clean them i do recommend an at-home
video otoscope these are about 35
it connects to your smartphone it's
super easy to use and you just take it
and look inside your ear while looking
on your smartphone and you can clearly
see if there is earwax or not but
sometimes these come with little tools
to get it out with i don't recommend
using the tools there are safer ways to
remove it at home or you could go see a
professional like an ear nose and throat
physician or an audiologist bad light
skin asked if q-tips can damage your ear
canal or pushes the earwax back how the
[ __ ] are we supposed to clean our ears
first of all q-tips they are the enemy
they are not helping us they even say on
the box do not put in your ears q-tips
what they're really doing is just
pushing any wax you have deeper into the
ear where it's much more sensitive and
it would make it a lot harder for me to
take it out of your ears i recommend not
using any objects blindly in your ears
the safest way to remove earwax would be
to use wax softening drops dbox is a
popular brand and i recommend using it
multiple times a day for a few days in a
row and using warm water flushes in
between this should be the most
effective way but if you don't feel
comfortable doing it at home or you've
tried it for a few days and it is not
working i do recommend seeing a
professional like an audiologist or an
ear nose and throat physician brauno
sweet b writes nephew what's a decibel
my dad a tenth of a bell obviously
a decibel is a way to measure the
intensity of a sound we can use it to
measure loudness so with an audiogram
that's a test showing how soft you can
hear we can tell you what decibel level
you can hear at for each frequency this
question is from maybe mickey why would
i wear earplugs to a concert i want
halsey to damage my ears
i mean don't we all but the truth is we
need to be protecting our hearing going
to a concert could be dangerous
depending on the decibel level of the
concert a recommendation i have is to
download a decibel meter they are free
on the app store and then you can
actually monitor how loud it is if you
are listening to something 80 decibels
you can only safely do that for eight
hours but once you go all the way up to
100 decibels you can only be there for
10 minutes without possibly causing any
sort of damage to your hearing and even
going up to 110 decibels technically you
can only be in that for safely one
minute and concerts are well over a
hundred decibels one of the biggest side
effects from noise exposure would be
hearing loss as well as tinnitus our
inner ear has thousands of hair cells
and i'm not just talking about hair
fibers these are sensory hair cells they
can become weak or break and we cannot
regenerate them so for example acoustic
trauma or repeated noise exposure they
will affect those hair cells and cause
damage to them and we can't regenerate
them so it's really important that we
protect them because we have one shot at
it all right bf knowles is asking that
hearing test where you sit in a booth
and listen to beeps the [ __ ] are they
testing for my ability to hear my wife
when she said under her breath
so
a hearing test consists of a lot of
different parts the first part would be
otoscopy where we look in your ears and
check for any debris wax anything
blocking the eardrum the next test would
be tympanometry where we move your
eardrum back and forth we're checking
the pressure in your ears the volume of
your ear canal and how well your eardrum
vibrates back and forth now what you are
referring to is the beep test we are
presenting different beeps at different
frequencies and we're trying to find the
softest sound that you can hear this is
how we measure hearing loss i'd say the
number one complaint people have when
they come into my office is that they
have trouble hearing in background noise
this is a very common complaint
everybody has trouble hearing in
background noise but what we do in the
office is we measure it's called a test
called the quicksin and we can measure
what signal to noise ratio your brain
needs to understand well in background
noise so the average listener who does
well in background noise only needs a
zero to two decibel advantage over the
background noise sometimes in the office
we'll find that some people have a 20
decibel signal to noise ratio meaning
let's say the background noise was at 60
decibels someone would have to speak to
them at 80 decibels so that much
difference over the background noise for
them to understand clearly this
question's from bao wilson i said what
causes tinnitus so there are a few
causes of tinnitus and first and
foremost tinnitus is a sound that you
are hearing inside of your ear nobody
else can hear it around you so it can
sound like a buzzing a ringing some
people say it's like cicadas in your ear
and some of the causes of tinnitus the
first one would be noise exposure some
other causes of tinnitus are infections
as well as stress and anxiety and
fatigue there are technically no
treatments for tinnitus that's probably
the number one question i get asked
online my first question is have you had
a hearing test because if you do have
hearing loss hearing aids are an amazing
way to mask the sound of your tinnitus i
have fit hearing aids on people who have
had tinnitus in their ears for 20 years
and they put the hearing aids on and
they said for the first time in decades
they have silence which is a really
powerful thing the next question is from
emma warner how do our ears affect our
balance a lot of people are unaware that
our balance organ is actually located in
the inner ear that is what you see right
here these are our semicircular canals
they actually detect gravity and
movement and that's what keeps us
upright and keeps us balanced vertigo is
when you experience a room spinning
sensation there are a few different
causes for that meniere's disease is a
disease that does have vertigo
accompanied with it head trauma
sometimes we see positional vertigo
which would mean if you turned your head
in one direction that would bring on
dizziness but if you turned your head
the other way no dizziness the dizziness
that happens with movement
what is happening there is we have
little calcium carbonate crystals in our
semicircular canals that are lodged
meaning they are stationary they can
become dislodged and when they are
free-floating it is hard to detect
gravity which will cause vertigo or
room-spinning dizziness there is a
maneuver that i recommend having a
professional do
don't look on youtube and do it yourself
definitely more effective if you see a
physical therapist who specializes in
vertigo or an ear nose and throat
physician or an audiologist that
specializes in vestibular issues the
next question is from manny edwards what
is the highest frequency you can hear
not humans in general but you
in general humans have the ability to
hear from 20 hertz all the way up to 20
000 hertz it's hard to know how high i
personally can hear because your
standard audio test
only goes up to 8 000 hertz there are
some high frequency testing at other
facilities a common thing we see in the
clinic is hearing loss due to aging
which is called presbycusis this
typically looks just like a high
frequency hearing loss we all do tend to
lose our high frequencies first that is
the most common configuration of a
hearing loss that i'll see in the office
and that's because how the ear is set up
our cochlea is snail shaped and the bass
sounds which are lower frequency they
get less attention than the high
frequency hair cells so we do see damage
to our hair cells more so in the high
frequencies we have a question from
kelly lek uh can my eardrum bursts on a
plane my right ear is blocked from
sickness and the plane pressure as we
descend is causing extremely sharp pain
yes your eardrum can burst on a plane
especially when you're having a sinus
infection or negative pressure in your
ear the sudden change when you're in an
airplane it's very fast which is why a
lot of us feel popping that's actually
your eustachian tube trying to regulate
atmospheric pressure to the pressure
behind your eardrum but in some rare
cases it can actually burst your eardrum
when the eardrum ruptures there is a
hole in the eardrum and most likely it
will repair itself but in rare cases it
does not and an ent can put a little
piece it's almost like a piece of
parchment paper that they put on the
eardrum so that the skin develops over
it so that you have a full solid eardrum
to keep your middle ear safe so i
recommend not traveling when you're too
sick make sure you see an ear nose and
throat physician before you travel and
see if there's anything they can do
to make you feel a little bit more
comfortable on the plane
meerkat skeptry
sent in a question asking i've lost my
hearing so badly that when my volume is
jacked all the way up it sounds normal
and not loud can you regain hearing if
this is the case i recommend you seeing
an audiologist for a hearing test there
are different kinds of hearing loss that
can be resolved through medication and
surgery an audiologist would be your
first step just to figure out what type
of hearing loss it is and then we would
refer out to an ear nose and throat
physician they prescribe medications and
do the surgery avibai
9947277 asked do cochlear implants give
people normal hearing abilities a
cochlear implant is actually able to
bypass the unhealthy part of the ear and
stimulate the auditory nerve directly a
cochlear implant does not sound like
what we experience hearing to sound like
people who did have normal hearing and
had normal speech and language skills
and then experienced a type of hearing
loss that required a cochlear implant
they often say that a cochlear implant
sounds very tinny or robotic but they do
learn to make sense of it with a lot of
speech therapy this is not a surgical
procedure that you do it and you're done
this is something that does require a
lot of follow-up with other
professionals and you do wear a part
that is on the outside of your head and
a part over the top of your ear where
the microphone is you'll oftentimes see
a circle attached with a wire right here
on the skull it stays there because
there's a piece behind the skin that
magnetizes the two together that is your
processor and that's actually going to
stimulate your auditory nerve and bypass
those unhealthy hair cells they have
come such a long way and people do
incredibly well with them katie likes
baseball asked any local audiologist out
there that can explain the yanny versus
laurel thing and why i hear a different
name every hour this was hysterical when
it came out and i too would go back and
forth between hearing them what's
happening is yani is a higher frequency
sounding word where laurel is lower
frequency so it just depends which one
your brain decided to listen to more so
the lower frequencies or the higher
frequencies kalma baljore wants to know
is the hearing aid business a big scam
unfortunately our profession has gotten
a little bit of a bad reputation because
of all of these advertisements you're
seeing out there there's a lot of
misinformation and it's really hard to
sift through that's why it's really
important to find an audiologist that
you trust anything that seems too good
to be true is too good to be true but if
you find an audiologist that knows what
they're doing and they truly care about
improving your life nothing scammy about
it it's actually a really incredible
profession to be in that's all the
questions that we have till next time
make sure you protect your ears
you